The third major evolutionary concept
that's useful in evolutionary medicine is
mismatch.
It is a major cause of mal
adaptation or disease. States
mismatch is often invoked
and it's frequently misused.
One has to be careful.
In thinking about causes of mismatch,
there was not a single environment
of evolutionary adaptation.
Our ancestors had many
different diets and lifestyles,
so any argument that invokes an imagined
past to support a favored hypothesis is
suspect.
It's biased.
The Paleo Diet movement is guilty
of suspect certainty on this point.
However,
mismatches real,
and it occurs in two ways in time.
The environment is changing faster
than the population can adapt.
The human examples include the
agricultural revolution, urbanization,
hygiene,
all producing mismatch to
evolve biology and in space.
Organisms can move from environments
where there were well adapted to
environments where they're not,
and the human examples would
be migration and immigration.
So let's first consider
mismatches in time.
Our Diet before agriculture
certainly was higher and lean meat,
fruit roots, nuts and seeds and
had less sugar, no refined starch,
less salt,
and there was no milk after weaning.
Our microbiota before hygiene
and antibiotics was more diverse.
Almost everyone had worms and our gut
flora was diverse and was often helpful.
Addictive substances and technologies were
rare or absence. There was no tobacco,
alcohol, heroin, or cocaine.
There was no television, email,
Twitter, or Facebook. There
were no horses to ride,
no bicycles,
cars or planes.
So those are all things
that have happened.
Some of them quite recently and others
within the last 10 or 20,000 years.
Yeah,
there was also more movement
unless sitting around.
So we had a different
diet and we exercise more.
Let's take the example of milk.
This one has been particularly
well investigated.
Evolution takes hundreds of generations
to adjust traits to new conditions.
That lag produced a serious mismatches
in our reactions to novel conditions.
What was novel about milk? Well,
lactase persistence in adults,
the ability to digest milk as adults is
something that only happened after the
agricultural revolution. Domesticated
dairy, cattle and goats and sheep.
If we look at the selection pressure
that might be required to produce the
change,
observe,
we can see that a mutation that enabled
the delts to digest lactose and gave
them a selective advantage of 5%
which is a big selective advantage,
would take about 8,000 years to increase
when 1% up to 90% in the population.
So that's a theoretical example.
What actually happened,
it was a bit more complicated.
There were both local responses to
selection and there was immigration from
areas where lactase persistence had
already started to evolve depending on the
region and the level of immigration.
The selective advantage of drinking
milk would actually have to have been
between about half a percent and 3% to
account for the patterns that we see both
today and in the archaeological record.
Only a few populations
are now 90% tolerance.
So what is the point of that example?
The first point is that the current
prevalence of primary lactose tolerance
ranges from 95 to 97% in Scandinavia
to zero to 10% in East Asia.
Not everyone on the planet
can digest milk. Is Nettle
strong selection and 8,000 years
was not enough to fix the trait.
Now that means that mismatches to
modernity or plausible for many traits,
not just lactose tolerance and adults.
So it gives us an example with a timeline
and a dynamic rate that shows us that
Lee's lags in biology are real
remote.
Ms Masters in space,
well migrants introduced new diseases,
so Columbus is sailors brought syphilis
back to Europe where it was initially
highly variant spreading from Naples
and routing the French army that was
invading Italy. Europeans on the
other hand introduced measles,
smallpox, bubonic plague,
influenza, typhus,
diphtheria and scarlet
fever to the new world.
And the Polynesia causing epidemics,
the killed from 20% to
over 90% of the natives.
So here is an example of tertiary syphilis
from the immune [inaudible] Olam and
Paris.
Here is an infant with measles
rash and here is scarlet fever.
Okay,
so these are all things that
were moved by migration.
Now immigrants also leaf
pathogens and symbiotes behind.
So when African Americans
came to North America,
they continue to suffer from sickle
cell anemia and that has compensating
advantages only when malaria is present.
Also,
immigrants that are currently coming
to develop countries suffer from eight
Hopis that may be related to
shifts in their microbiomes.
International adoptees and children born
in Sweden to foreign born parents used
asthma medications three to four times
as often as did foreign born children.
So immigration of also involves a switch
in the Microbiota and that cascades
through communication with the immune
systems and if the immune system is
mismatched to the Microbiota
are getting the wrong signal,
then you can have one of the diseases
that result from immune malfunction.
There is a general lesson in this.
We are adapted to things that
happened frequently in our past.
Reproductive success occurs much more
frequently in the young than in the old
and in supportive environments and
then healthy bodies than in threatening
environments and in sick bodies.
That means that do you the
young are better adapted add
that healthy bodies are better
adapted than are sick bodies.
We are adapted to circumstances that
frequently led to reproductive success in
the past.
We are not adapted to circumstances
that we did not encounter in the past.
So things that happen very frequently
with small effects can accumulate to have
large effects. That is another, uh,
thing about the numbers game of evolution.
For example,
anything involved in protein synthesis
is going to be very finely adjusted
because that's something that is
going on in every cell in the body.
So that by the time
reproduction actually occurs,
there has been a history
in that individual organism
of trillions of protein
synthesis events that that's something
that can be extremely finally adjusted.
We're mismatched or things that happened
rarely or never before. And we are,
we'll matched to things that
happen frequently. So in summary,
although the concept of mismatches
often misused, mismatch is real,
the evolution of lactase persistence
shows that ms masters in time are real.
We are mismatched to conditions that
are encountered rarely or never before.
And we can also be mismatched to things
that happen in other environments,
but not in this one.
So migration and immigration
are also sources of mismatch.